I have to admit when when I am taking
Pleasure in someone else's misery I
admit it to you guys I do I don't hide
that Donald Trump's truth social is
collapsing truth essential they owe more
than a million dollars to their web
hosting company and according to Tom
boggione for salon.com the platform is
rapidly heading for bankruptcy I admit
it I am taking pleasure in this I am
Donald Trump's truth social is facing
some very serious financial problems
they reportedly owe the web hosting
company that they use more than a
million dollars already
they are having problems with some of
their intellectual property uh trademark
uh registrations in a filing this week
Digital World acquisition which planned
to take the Trump media and Technology
Group public is now issuing warnings
about what the future may bring isn't
that sad quote the company warned this
week that its businesses could be
damaged if Trump becomes less popular or
there are further controversies that
damage his credibility
the company has seen its stock price
plunge nearly 75 percent since its March
Peak and reported in a filing last week
it lost
6.5 million dollars in the first half of
the year the company's Financial base
has begun to erode the Trump company
stopped paying right Forge a
conservative web hosting service in
March and now owes it more than a
million dollars this is a I'm going to
tell you guys this is a delightful fate
and I have to tell you I'm not taking
pleasure in this because I want some
authoritarian censorship of the platform
I'm taking pleasure in it because it's
the free market deciding the platform is
so lame no one cares it's not popular
producer Pat mentioned on the bonus show
yesterday that many people have accounts
only to be able to see what other people
are posting not because they want to
post anything just because you have to
have an account at last we check in
order to see the things that are posted
here's a report from MSNBC about this
former president Trump's social media
platform is facing money problems right
now
come and if it doesn't get any it could
go bust a new SEC filing from the
company planning to take truth social
public is warning of damages to the
already slowing business president quote
becomes less popular or there are
further controversies that damages
credibility now this comes as the
platform has reportedly stopped paying
its web hosting service and now owes it
more than one million dollars this
according to Fox Business
let's bring in NBC News senior reporter
Ben Collins and here's why we're
bringing in Ben because you're an expert
on the internet this is really the best
so my first question is just how popular
or not popular is truth social I mean
does the former president have reason to
be concerned yes it's not popular at all
let's be real about this uh Donald Trump
is the primary user on that platform and
even he only gets a few thousand uh
likes or what they call them recruits
for a post there his website exists so
it can be screenshotted and posted onto
bigger platforms Facebook and Twitter
places that he has been banned from he
wants to be able to tweet this is his
way to tweet all right anyway so I think
you guys get what's going on um this
this is a what's great about this is the
right lives in an imaginary world and
one of the totally fantasy world beliefs
that the right has constructed about
social media obviously that right
Wingers are being overwhelmingly
censored and depressed by the
jack-booted uh terms of service
moderators or whatever the case may be
but also that there's just massive
demand from right Wingers for a
so-called Free Speech platform and that
as soon as one is available they're
going to flock to it right away Twitter
was copied over into truth growth
Central it's just a clone it looks just
like Twitter they just copied it so when
it comes to the functionality you would
think that if there was really such a
demand that wouldn't be an impediment to
people going over to Truth uh but people
aren't doing it and it's because there
isn't actually demand for that I hope
that it fails and it seems to be going
in that direction
here's something fun for Labor Day our
sponsor established titles is a Project
based on the historic Scottish custom
where landowners are called Lords and
Ladies established titles allows you to
ceremonially purchase as little as a
square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or lady you get an
official certificate with a Crest they
let you see exactly where your plot is
located and here's really the cool part
a tree is planted for every plot of land
sold established titles also does really
great work with organizations doing
environmental work all over the world
like one tree planted and trees for the
future so it's a fun gift but you're
also supporting something great which is
the real gift you're helping to preserve
the picturesque woodlands and
biodiversity of Scotland and supporting
Global reforestation efforts it makes a
great last minute gift they even have
couple packs that come with adjoining
plots of land established titles is
giving my audience 10 off when you go to
establishtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below